as in nearly every corner of the world
they're cleaning and disinfecting in
Bangkok's densely populated low-income
community of clonk doing doing
everything they can to prevent the
spread of kovat 19 from reaching their
family and neighbors plan yasiel adapt
has spent all 56 years of his life in
clonk dewey most as a community leader
and a volunteer fireman I am worried
because we are in a crowded community
with a lot of people living here there
are 594 households I have to be worried
we need to make everyone understand how
we should cohabitate use face masks and
stay indoors as much as possible the way
disease outbreaks have impacted dense
urban areas like during the flu pandemic
in the early 1900s has played a role in
how our cities look and run today
the disease in the way threat threatened
the city in a way also shaped the city
and shape urban planning so they it gave
to new standards new knowledge a new
theory urban planners reacted to that
flu and other outbreaks changing how
cities were zoned and led to updated
infrastructure like ventilation and
improved sanitation but after what's
been learned from pandemics and their
influences on our skylines and way of
life we also need to keep pace and adapt
it's easy to assume that cities are
fertile ground for spreading viruses and
diseases millions living working at
commuting in such tight conditions but
one expert says it's about much more
than just a density it's about how all
this was put together and how it's run
does it even get in here to be very
clear and if you serve a fairly
simplistic reading the same density is
the problem is so it is much more about
the design and the management of that
density that is really the story here so
for now in those communities with few
resources a great deal of responsibility
rests with people like pan young
hopefully everything we do we do to
control and make sure the safety in our
community
and hopefully at some point soon
community leaders and urban planners
will take what was learned from the
spread of a corona virus and stop it
from happening again or at least slow it
down during the next outbreak Scott
Heidler al Jazeera Bangkok